Hi everyone.
Welcome to toxic Google.
My name is Olivia Ma and I'm so,
so honored to welcome Bob Odenkirk and Tom Hanks today to discuss their roles in
the upcoming Steven Spielberg film,
The post,
which hits theaters on December 22nd so please join me in welcoming Bob Odenkirk
and Tom Hanks.
So
first of all,
I just want to thank you all for taking the time to join us here at the youtube
space in New York.
Um,
it's such an honor and such a time we movie to be discussing today.
I also just want to start by saying this is a deeply personal for me because my
father,
my late father worked for a long time as an executive,
as an editor and executive at the Washington Post Company.
He worked under Kay Graham when he first got his start and then leader for his,
for his son Donald.
And so seeing the movie last night,
which I had the pleasure of doing was,
was really,
really meaningful.
Uh,
and so I just want to start by asking about the timing of all of this.
You know,
uh,
it's been reported that Steven Spielberg got the script in Ma in March,
I believe.
And then you all started filming in May and here we are in December.
And the film is about to hit the theaters.
Talk a little bit about why you felt like it was important to make this movie
now and what the urgency was
first.
Cause I'm hip to some of this stuff and Bob's not.
So,
uh,
Amy Pascal who is a producer,
red,
uh,
Liz Hannah's draft spec script that was written in,
in October.
Uh,
we read it,
uh,
in a by that I think Steven and marijuana.
When did you read it for the first time after you were at or know when did it
start shooting?
Well,
we read,
I read it in February and we,
the first day of shooting was may,
which is a brutally short post for a preproduction time.
Uh,
and,
uh,
we,
my last day was I think the 26th of July,
so it shot that fast.
But at the same time,
Liz,
Hannah screenplay was really about Katharine Graham,
uh,
becoming Katharine Graham.
The Pentagon papers were presented in it as though it was,
uh,
you know,
the treasure chest,
but we didn't know what was inside the treasure chest.
Josh singer who wrote a spotlight among many other things,
he ended up teaming up with,
uh,
with,
Liz because Steven wanted more information,
more details,
more of the procedure that went on in to this week of American history so that
we were constantly working with new pages,
new materials.
There were whole scenes that didn't exist until,
for example,
we met,
um,
uh,
Daniel Ellsberg who leaked the Pentagon papers for the Rand Corporation.
And there are scenes in the movie that came directly from our,
uh,
our talk with him.
So it was a,
it was greatly influx from the moment we first read it right up until the last
day we shot.
Yeah.
Does that answer the timeliness of it or it,
it just so happens that we're making a movie that took place in 1971.
And if you invert the,
uh,
the integers to 17,
it's like we're making a movie about current events.
Yeah.
They're,
they're certainly,
it was a lot of residents with,
uh,
some of the events that are happening in the world today.
Um,
talk to me a little about preparing for these roles and what the research
process was like.
You mentioned you had the opportunity to talk with Daniel Ellsberg,
who of course was a critical player in this entire story.
Um,
you know,
what was it like to sort of really immerse yourself in the culture of a 1970s
newsroom?
And you knew Tom Knew Ben Bradley,
which is pretty cool.
I had met Ben Bradlee,
um,
through Nora Ephron.
Uh,
and this was years ago.
I act,
believe it or not,
I actually met Katharine Graham the day she died.
Uh,
that was a fluky thing.
Wow.
We didn't know that was happening to the service you provide.
Yeah.
That's,
that's how deep I was willing to go into the research.
Uh,
but,
uh,
but knowing that they're,
there is a boy.
Katharine Graham wrote this amazing a autobiography as did,
as did Ben.
And there's oceans of video,
there's a lot of material that you can find out,
uh,
about the particulars.
But digging into the process of the,
the pre Watergate pre all the president's men version of the Washington Post,
that was,
that was just grunt work.
We met an awful lot of people and we just asked them every possible question we
could about how to get the paper out and the importance of this week and the
history of it because it really wasn't an assault on the first amendment.
The New York Times was,
I think the word is in joined are conjoined.
They were,
they,
they were forced to stop publishing by the Justice Department and the idea of
the Washington Post saying,
well,
we've got,
we've got the papers as well.
So we're going to do whether they ran a flush into the danger of being
imprisoned for treason,
uh,
for giving up of national a national secrets.
Uh,
and on mine,
I'm an Lord from that is also the background of the paper itself because they
were not,
the Washington Post at that time was not just competing with the New York Times
for national prominence.
They weren't even the number one paper in Washington DC.
The Washington Star,
which never doesn't exist anymore,
was the number one paper,
Washington DC.
So you get all this kind of magnificent flexing of journalistic muscles.
I mean,
you know,
Ben Bradley was just,
he was a man possessed.
He was,
he was,
uh,
he was a hunting dog when it came down to doing the work of the fourth estate.
And Katherine Graham had to deal with the realities of her father started the
newspaper and when he died he gave the newspaper to her husband,
not her.
So her husband ran it.
Their son,
Don had actually served in Vietnam and uh,
at the,
at the whims of history and these,
these papers,
uh,
that study that had been a commissioned and had been sitting around the rand for
for years,
divulged just the,
what's the word,
the rocky road in which American involvement got into this thing that was
killing,
that was killing about 8,000 young Americans every year.
Uh,
and to the total of 52,000,
I think died.
So a,
it ends up being this,
this treaties on people who understand that they're dealing,
they have to have a degree of cynicism because both Ben bag,
dicky in and everybody in the newsroom and,
and Ben Bradlee and k knew that elected officials lie in order to curry favor
and hold onto their power.
And yet that cynicism could not give way to,
uh,
a,
a blanket statement or a desire just to run with anything that is not,
that was not the provable codafide a research driven truth that they then ended
up finding out.
And that's really what the struggle is day in and day out.
And the six days it was paper.
My research was,
I Read Ben Beg Dickins Autobiography,
which is a great book.
He's a great journalist.
Gave his whole life to journalism.
You cared about it deeply and uh,
it was a great youtube interview with him.
And so how do you find that Youtube,
what do you do?
You gotta get one of these fancy computers?
Well,
I'm gonna let's go ask,
let's go down to the library.
This building and a woman goes down an aisle and she finds the file.
Uh,
actually I wanted to ask about your,
your character Ben,
back to him because um,
you know,
he's somewhat of a lesser known character,
but he had this essential role and actually acquiring the Pentagon papers from
Daniel Ellsberg and there's an incredible scene in the hotel room when you go to
actually meet him to get the papers and you promise him that you are going to
publish them.
And I want to talk about that scene.
Yeah.
And just like the courage at that,
that is sort of on manifested in that in that moment.
I think it's balls and not so much courage because Ben isn't utterly,
completely sure that it will get published.
He's assuring Ellsberg so you can have the story,
but any wants it to be published.
He thinks it's the right thing to do,
I think.
But you know,
he,
he didn't run the paper and he knew that whenever you hand stuff over to the,
the bosses,
even though I think he was tight with Bradley,
I'm not sure how long they'd worked together,
but it seems to me,
it seems like they'd worked together for a couple of years.
And,
uh,
and he was a seasoned reporter by the time he got hired there.
So I imagine they had a comradeship of years of journalism,
uh,
shared.
And uh,
but he,
he had a promise Helzberg he would publish it in order to walk away with the
papers.
He also had to take a second set of the papers,
which he always felt bad about because it went against his,
um,
rules of being a journalist.
Um,
Ellsberg asked him to take two copies of the,
the papers,
one to give to the Washington Post and one that he secretly gave to a
congressman to read into the record,
into the congressional record,
thereby making it public.
And,
um,
after the Washington Post did with,
you know,
published papers and got in trouble alongside the New York Times,
then a beg dicky and did deliver the papers to a senator whose name,
I can't remember,
who didn't read all the papers,
but he read a chunk,
he read a couple hours worth into the congressional record.
So there's no,
that has to be public.
So thereby getting kind of any which way kind of breaking this code of silence
on them.
Yeah.
Do you think if,
if this moment happens today,
that journalists working in the environment,
would,
that we're living in today?
We would make the same decision?
Oh,
absolutely.
I,
I think one of the things that has been learned from this checkered period of
our history is that you have to take to the barricades at some point.
And they would,
uh,
the,
what's interesting is the assault that would go on in regards to the first
amendment would not be the same as it was in 1971 at that time,
they had the power in order to literally cease the presses from operating and
making it impossible to literally physically publish the information.
Uh,
that what's going on now is a different sort of assault on the first amendment
if sort of fight it is a constant,
uh,
de-legitimizing of the truth,
which at the same time raises up the legitimacy of what truly is a false media.
Uh,
you can decry,
oh,
that's just fake news,
that just fake news that comes out into the mainstream media.
Uh,
but they,
they go the extra distance in order to have the multiple,
multiple sources.
And so all of this stuff can be confirmed.
And yet there is also,
as we know,
uh,
you know,
oceans of a,
of outlets that don't,
that don't give a damn about the truth and forcefully or,
or are,
are putting out news that they know themselves.
It's false.
And in that way,
that's a different sort of assault on,
let's understand that you can take the first amendment of the Constitution and
maybe not even bother with the rest of them because in that first amendment is
we are guaranteed this,
the,
the no government will establish a national religion.
So we have freedom of religion.
They cannot stop us from a Freedom of assembly,
which means we get to hang out with likeminded people.
We have freedom of speech in order to say anything we want to short of yelling
fire in a crowded theater when there is no fire and a freedom of the press,
you cannot stop the press from Walter,
uh,
from,
from existing take that that literally is the foundation for the American
democracy and all of a,
all of Western society when you,
when you can,
when you try to conspire in order to attack any one of those,
uh,
on any form,
you are doing this,
you're doing literally the same work of a,
at an administration that was truly taking on and putting the,
the uh,
the force of a government behind the ceasing of,
um,
of publication and therefore,
uh,
removing the right to uh,
the freedom of the press.
Totally agree.
I think one of my favorite fun facts about you,
which I think maybe you should confirm here,
is that you send a coffee maker to the White House press corps.
Has that happened
a long ago?
Uh,
when I was just a visitor,
uh,
we visited the empty a White House press room and there were,
there were like three people there.
It has to be staffed 24 hours a day because something goes on.
Someone's got to be there to turn on the cameras and the microphone and start
rolling.
And I saw they had the saddest,
oldest,
shittiest little mister coffee that had already been there for like 12 years at
guys,
you need a new coffee maker.
So I sent them a pretty good espresso machine,
but that was like 15 years ago.
And when I went back and saw it again,
it was the same,
same espresso maker.
I said,
guys,
come on.
So I sent them a new one for so then they could pursue truth,
justice and the American way and it's,
and it's open for everybody.
Any,
any member of the press car could get a decent,
decent cup of coffee now.
Well Bob,
I wanted to ask you a little bit about your decision to take on this role
because your,
your career has really spanned a lot of different genres.
You've done Mr. Show and comedy and then of course breaking bad and better call
Saul.
What was it like to work with Steven Spielberg on a historical film?
It was very intimidating and I felt like I felt out of place.
I really did.
And shows hardship.
Oh well we tricked you.
We,
uh,
they used only the good takes.
That's how they did a,
it was truly the,
I haven't been this intimidated in like 30 years since I first got hired at SNL
where I wrote for this guy when I was 25.
And so it's like literally that's how long it's been since I had that feeling
that I had on this movie of like,
I am going to be fired.
I should be fired.
I should call them,
you should fire me.
But it just felt like it was just,
look,
you know,
I've been very lucky to work on some great dramas on TV Fargo and breaking bad
and all,
and these are respected projects and great,
great creators and stuff,
but this was another level.
And,
uh,
I've always loved Tom's work so much and Steven Spielberg is it,
you know,
it's just,
he's an icon,
you know,
and uh,
so it was intimidating,
but Steven's very nice.
And Luckily I played a guy who I could relate to,
I think,
beg Dickins,
um,
anxious energy coupled with his,
uh,
in his,
in his biography he talks about learning to fade into the woodwork.
That's like,
uh,
he learned as a journalist to just quiet himself down to get people to talk.
And I thought I maybe it was able to combine those using my natural nervousness
to both recede away from the camera and then,
uh,
you know,
be a energetic when needed.
So it was really fun.
And I had some comedy in it too with the,
the nerves of trying to get the phone call to happen cause I have some tenuous
connection to Ellsberg Beg Dicky and actually worked with Ellsberg at rand and
he sort of put together in his mind who would have,
uh,
the,
hoods,
but,
uh,
put these papers out and he chase down Ellsberg and,
and it was a tricky thing to get the papers and Ellsberg was,
you know,
scared that he was going to get arrested.
So there was a lot of tension in my scenes and I get to use that,
you know,
use my own natural,
a nervousness to play it,
I guess it played well.
I feel good about it.
And you know,
obviously I think a lot of you have seen the movie.
Anybody.
Yeah.
A couple of you.
I mean we're,
one thing we haven't talked about is Merrill and I'm Katherine Graham and,
and Tom was talking about how that early draft,
uh,
Liz Hannah's draft was very much about her journey as a woman to own her power
that she had been given.
But she and w internally was like,
I don't know if I have a right to this.
As smart as she was,
as composed as she was as a person,
it just was such,
not,
it was so not done.
And it was so not something she was familiar with,
uh,
that it was hard for her to assume the power that she'd been granted granted,
and that was hers.
And so in this movie,
in the course of the story,
you watch her grow into that.
It's really an amazing thing alongside everything that Tom said about the
stories of getting the papers and fighting back against the government and
getting the crackdown and sorting out this mystery,
the suspense actually have that.
It's a mix of so many things.
This movie and that story is all there from Liz's script.
I mean,
two of my favorite moments are of the movie are when Kay Graham makes the
decision on the phone to go ahead and say,
yes,
we're going to publish.
Now.
My other favorite movie moment is when she's walking down the steps of the
Supreme Court.
Oh yeah,
it's this holy cow.
All of these women are looking at her with a sense of awe and inspiration.
Here's the one of my favorite scenes,
not because I just because it worked so well when she goes to that board room
and she's all prepared,
she's going to give this presentation and it's all men and they don't,
they look right pastor,
as she talks,
no one listens to her.
And the way that plays out,
you feel it,
you feel her being ignored and you're like,
it's crazy to it.
And the moment that we're living in right now was,
wait,
I'm going to ask one more question then everyone here at please have your
questions ready.
I want to ask you,
Tom,
you know,
I was surprised to learn this was actually the first project you'd ever done
with,
with Meryl Streep.
Um,
talk about what that was like to work with her.
And then if there's other,
you know,
actors that either of you had,
would have always wanted to work with.
Well you dare not assemble a list cause as soon as you do,
you'll,
it'll never happen.
It's just,
it's just bad luck.
And you know,
my,
there,
we had never just been in projects in which there was a Meryl Streep role that
we could go to for her.
A gold go to her for or,
and I guess vice versa.
I mean,
I can't sing a lick,
so there was no way I could put myself in Mama Mia that,
that the,
that which would have been,
you know,
the clothes I could get,
the intimidation factor is truly off the scale.
I mean,
we,
we knew each other,
we met each other.
I would say hello to each other,
but the,
the mystery of Merrill is how does she do it?
And it turns out she does it just like anybody else does.
You know,
you,
you sit,
you'll run your lines a bunch.
She starts,
she stopped,
she goes back and forth.
She's part of an ensemble and yet she's so,
she does it like everybody else,
but she does it unlike anybody else.
There's no,
there's one way to do it that,
that,
that scene where she has it,
she's only ever been either the the daughter or the wife of the person who ran
the paper and that moment where she's getting yelled at on the phone by people
who are saying under no circumstances can you publish.
Well,
I don't think you should because if it was me,
I wouldn't do other people saying,
if you don't publish,
we're going to resign.
Because there's no sense of being a journalist if you're not going to run with
this.
And that decision is placed solely on her.
And I,
I,
uh,
my voices in it,
are you on the phone to know?
But you're,
you're in the other room when it's all going on.
Yeah.
You,
you,
you threatened to a,
you threatened to resign and you don't know what's going to happen.
And I think it's one of the,
it's,
it's a powerful moment.
And I think the history of cinema coming from,
she'd hate if I said this to it,
but I think the greatest actor who has ever been on cellulose,
Meryl Streep.
All right.
We're going to take a few questions from the audience.
There's a microphone here and yeah,
so I'll start with you.
Okay.
Thank you guys so much for being here.
Big Fans of both of you.
Um,
really,
really quickly.
Tom,
I wanted to tell you a fast story.
My mom is such a huge fan.
She was about to give birth to my brother in labor or having contractions while
you were about to win the academy award.
She didn't want to go to the hospital because she wanted to see you when she
went to the hospital after as much urging and was able to see when and then
successfully delivered my brother.
So she's a big fan.
Uh,
is your brother okay?
What's his name is Forrest Gump.
Yeah.
Um,
but huge bandwidth though,
right?
The prelude.
Is your brother a smart or is he
very glad to hear that.
Um,
I wanted to ask,
I thought that was very eloquent in your description of your,
sort of the changing nature of technology in terms of disclosures back when this
movie takes place.
And you know,
currently how a lot of disclosures are affecting politics today.
It,
it made me wonder for both of you,
you know,
has ever working on a movie,
especially when that's political,
like this really challenged or changed any of your opinions about sort of a
strongly held belief that you had going into it?
Uh,
I mostly did comedy in my life and I made fun of stuff that came from my brain.
And so I,
uh,
um,
you know,
I don't,
I don't have a,
no,
I would say that hasn't happened for me.
The,
the thing that happens when you,
you,
you take on a job because you think you know enough of the story and then in the
process of it,
you end up learning more and more and more and more until you find out.
Literally,
I didn't know that.
Um,
uh,
I made this when I'm made this movie called,
um,
well most recently,
uh,
the movie a Sally about Shazli's rude for landed the plane out on,
on the Hudson.
Uh,
all of the,
uh,
industry and union and Ntsb National Transportation Safety Board pressures that
is on somebody who did that was extremely eye opening.
It made you number one,
maybe not want to fly on a commercial airliner anymore because you find out how
little they're paying their pilots,
uh,
and how they cut costs.
Uh,
but also,
uh,
he,
for 18 months,
he had no idea if he was going to be found,
uh,
responsible for,
for landing the plane of the way he did,
in which case he would have lost his license and would have lost his,
uh,
his,
his literally the way that he could make a living and find that stuff out.
And you kind of think really,
and yet those are,
those are the Yukon pine out.
These common ordinary details of truth with makes the original reason we want to
do the movie even kind of like grander because you just find out how much truly
is is at stake.
Okay.
You're welcome.
Hi.
So,
um,
Mr Hanks,
your Instagram is one of my all time favorites and doing the important work of
documenting a femora around the world.
Um,
and I was wondering,
you've spoken so articulately today about some of the challenges facing and how
do you consider using your platforms and speaking publicly about things that are
going on versus doing fun,
things like that that,
um,
just bring a little pleasure to people's lives.
You know,
it's interesting because I do,
do you have a big internet social platforms?
My,
my issue is that I,
I did comedy for 25 years.
Pretty straight.
Just that.
No.
And so I have s fans from that world and it's very critical world and they're
used to my political opinion.
And then I have a larger group of people who've seen me in drama.
So,
even though I spent most of my life with these fans who would completely
understand if I made a
cynical or crass political comment,
I have to be careful because I'm,
I have more fans who don't know I ever spoke up about my opinion about anything.
And they think I'm a dramatic actor.
And if I were to say something,
um,
pointed,
they might feel insulted and wonder why I'm even commenting.
So I keep my mouth shut.
I'm trying to navigate this thing.
I don't know what to do.
I think,
uh,
I think the desire is for authenticity in whatever you put out there.
And if you're,
if,
if you have eight bajillion followers and you're going to use them in order to
sell your new product or steer them towards something that you're actually being
paid to endorse,
I think that's disingenuous.
And it removes the,
removes the great promise of what all this connectivity,
uh,
was,
was meant to,
to provide.
I,
I don't,
I don't care.
By and large what most people have to say about the,
uh,
the,
the issue of the day or,
you know,
it's like this,
you were in where the ice bucket challenge came around,
but that was just a great thing.
But you can't create that again.
You can't suddenly,
you know,
uh,
just by putting it out there,
make a,
make something become as important as that.
There is a natural kind of like microbiology to all this stuff.
And I,
I,
when,
you know,
I don't,
I,
I put up visual Haikus and every now and again,
you know,
post,
uh,
pictures of,
you know,
guys I knew who fought in World War II,
who passed away and just say,
Godspeed,
thanks for being there because I,
at the end of the day,
I just,
I don't trust somebody who uses it for an agenda,
be it either self serving or you know,
can be,
like you said,
saying,
uh,
oh,
I have something important to say about this.
And I'm not saying they,
okay,
fine,
but I don't have to pay attention to it.
So.
Well,
thank you.
Thank you.
All right.
Okay,
I'll I,
it means you look out and look or wander around and look at the ground a lot.
You got to like always be looking down.
And why do people always lose pacifiers from,
there's babies.
There's millions of pacifiers lying on the streets all the time.
I don't know why.
Yeah,
well,
but we,
if you,
if in order to use them,
you've got to run them through your dishwashers.
So I'd like to watch TV with a found pacifier in my mouth
sometimes.
What's up?
Hi,
I'm Diana.
I run a channel about physics,
so I have to ask an important question about the universe,
which is a definitely related.
Why do you post pictures of the Solo Mittens?
There's a story behind every one of those mittens.
It belonged to somebody.
They got it as a gift.
They bought it.
Sometimes it's an expensive gloves.
Sometimes it's a cheap one.
But I just like to thank,
someone was walking around and you know,
their mind was somewhere else and they put their glove on and they walked a
little bit more and they reached for the other one.
And where did it go?
What's going on in their lives.
Why did they do that?
And the one that really gets me his little baby booties would you find a little
baby booty?
So it needs,
some kid was rolled around in a stroller in the middle of February and probably
lost their toes to frostbite.
You know,
they had to go to the emergency room was,
it was a big thing there.
There is,
there was,
there was a before and after story that goes along with those,
uh,
those gloves that I just find who hasn't lost a glove in this world.
And uh,
I think it unifies us.
It's the great promise of social media brings us,
it brings us all together,
doesn't it?
In the form of one loss.
Glover or mitten.
Thank you for resolving the mystery.
You Go.
Okay.
Hi,
Mr hangs high.
I'm a super big fan.
Um,
and thank you for having us here all day today.
So I'm a youtube creator.
Um,
my neck,
I'm from India.
Channel Name Is Rick shall volley.
So I don't want to,
I can't talk too much.
I'll say it very quickly.
So do you think,
cause this be all youtube creators here,
do you think,
um,
is it ever a way that there is a bridge that we creators can have a bridge to
traditional cinema?
Do you think that's ever possible being on youtube or what is your view on that?
Okay,
well I think you guys are already creating original cinema.
Um,
I th years go by,
I think we always get this kind of question of how,
how can I get started in show business?
You know,
and the answer is get started in show business.
Come up with something and you know,
put it on,
you can use your phone,
you can use something decent.
How many people actually do create original stories as opposed to things that
are going on in their lives?
See,
um,
you guys are the,
the,
the nature of how we are entertained is in flux now and it's not going to land
for quite some time.
How we pay for our entertainment is going to be determined.
And the only,
I think the only guarantee is,
or the only this biggest signposts of it is,
is going to be the quality of that entertainment.
I mean we all know people that put on different sweaters and they say,
I don't like the way this sweater,
I just hearing a story about somebody does it like that.
And it turns out they get paid in order to put on a certain sweater.
What happened?
That's commerce.
It's not art.
If you're creating original stories out there,
it is art.
And as people discover you,
cause you put anything on youtube,
it's going to be there for the rest of time.
It will be part of your library will be part of your historical output and you
will attract people who are anxious to see what you are going to come up with
next.
And as soon as they are that they're willing to pay for that the to a certain
degree.
So,
uh,
I mean you,
you will be able to,
anybody who does it in as good as it and pursues it will be able to attract not
only the audience,
but some ways out there seeking to have an alliance with you because they want
good content and they want,
they want to take it up to whatever the next level.
So I would say there's no individual path to quote unquote legitimate cinema
because what's,
what's the difference between someone who never goes to the movies,
but it says watches everything on either their phone or their,
their,
their laptop.
The different,
there is no difference,
are seeking entertainment and they want good entertainment and they want to be
inspired by what you do.
So the answer is just keep doing it and it's going
to happen.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Great.
Thank you all so much.
We're running out of time,
but a really big round of applause for Tom
[inaudible].